i'm pro-woman i love me some women and i
love me some pretty [ __ ]
[Laughter]
hey what's up it's sweetie and this is
my glamour unfiltered
growing up i hated my hair my hair
naturally is really kinky and curly and
it's beautiful but i was a tomboy and i
was like i don't have no time for this
i actually got in trouble with my mom
because i convinced her mom my grandma
to cut my hair off in the kitchen
because i was just so tired of having to
comb my hair out every time i washed it
it would take like
just forever my arms were hurt so i had
her cut all my hair off to like right
here
i just remember always wanting to have
straight hair and when i would
compliment you know another girl with
straight hair like she wouldn't
compliment me back
[Laughter]
so at a young age i just felt like my
hair
it like personally i just didn't like it
i just felt like it was it was very high
maintenance and not easy to do and
i honestly didn't love my natural hair
texture until senior year of high school
i was a year-round athlete but i noticed
that my hair was just so curly and wild
that i didn't need to do it at all it
was just pretty the way it was
so i think just me playing a lot of
sports not having time to do my hair and
me just seeing like how wild it was
that's when i really started to
appreciate my hair i felt like
it went with
my style of an athlete like
i was a hardcore athlete very aggressive
very
ambitious and i felt like my hair
represented that so i fell in love with
my hair probably like
my varsity years of high school
i think the first step of progress
for accepting all hair textures is just
to stop touching people's hair
you know like
i hate that i don't touch my hair
the compliment serves its purpose but
trying to touch the hair after that is
not cool so i think that's the first
step we can take
i mean the first hair hero is definitely
my mother
her hair was hella thick and hella long
like her hair is just so thick and
luscious i love cher's hair cher is
definitely on my mood board all day
every day i love me a bone straight
moment middle part nice and silky and
flowy i definitely see a difference to
where i'm wearing like long bone
straight hair so when i'm bald to when
i'm wearing curly hair to win
i wear braids it's definitely a
different energy and maybe i don't know
maybe it's the energy i give off but i
definitely think that
different types of hairstyles attract
different types of people
i actually
shaved it off because fourth quarter of
last year i learned about meditation and
the more deeper of an understanding i
got of the spirituality
self alignment
purpose
i just wanted to start over with
everything and hair holds energy and i
was like dang this hair been with me
since
i don't know and i'm ready for a fresh
start so that's what made me cut my hair
to keep my mental health in check i
definitely
meditate
i drink a lot of water
i try to
it definitely makes a difference like
water is a drug
a good one like your body needs that
i try to stay off of social media
because of course you want to learn as
much about yourself as possible but
sometimes autumn rabbit holes not good
hoes
you read the wrong thing and be ready to
fight somebody so i actually have a
screen timer now so it lets me know if
i'm on there too long
growing up
i don't even know if there's a word for
this but word that i identified with the
most is just
not belonging like it's like i'm not
black enough or i'm not asian enough so
it's like where do i fit in so i always
was confused
as a little girl i didn't really feel
like i belonged
in any group at school the only place
where i felt like i belonged was at home
i think um as people mature
it doesn't necessarily become a
a thing of you don't belong here it's
kind of like people see past race see
past skin color see past ethnicity and
just kind of see you for your soul
but as a little kid you know little kids
are mean
so when you got these little girls
telling you
you don't belong here then you got
another group of girls saying you don't
belong here either it's just like damn
where do i belong
so it was something i definitely had a
lot of identity crisis as a little girl
just struggling to figure out where i
belong
i've watched my dad get pulled over for
no reason get out the car and him having
to
appear lesser of a man you know because
he's superman to me but you know when
the cops come and they pull him over he
has to
you know confine to a certain type of um
of submissiveness it's always angered me
you know experiencing that watching the
videos but i'm actually thankful that we
have phones now because now the world is
witnessing what black and brown and
asian communities go through behind the
scenes and it's not nothing new it's
been happening for a very very long time
so what inspired the icy baby foundation
was i was tired of giving away a lot of
money to other foundations and not
knowing what they did with my money so
i trust my grandmother and
as a kid i watched her give back i
watched her go to high schools i watched
her go to other churches i watched it go
to into other people's homes well the
number one initiative is definitely
financial literacy
and the reason why i'm so sensitive to
that is because
i need to help my damn self
you know just putting money in the
savings account is not enough especially
not enough to create generational wealth
for you your family or your kids so i
think that it's important that we
educate these young kids so that it's
something that's instilled into their
mind so that it's innate it's second
nature it's not something that they're
like
you know trying to figure out as an
adult because it's something that i'm
trying to do at this age so i know that
if i can go back into and educate these
little kids and little boys they're
going to be set uplifting those who look
like me has always been
an important you know goal in my life
since i was a little girl because i
would be right there next to my grandma
helping other people so i think that
it's important that i use my platform to
help others
you know feminism is a touchy word but i
think that it's slowly evolved to a
common goal of women being accepted
empowered and equal to everyone on the
planet
so i'm proud woman i love me some women
and i love me some pretty [ __ ]
[Laughter]
uplifting women is so important to me
because i didn't have a big sister so i
had to figure out a lot of things
on my own point of me sharing is to make
sure that all those little girls who
don't have a mom a big sister a best
friend at least they're learning from
the mistakes i made or learning from
wisdom i gain i've definitely
experienced sexism and misogyny but not
just in the industry but in sports it's
so
easy for me to deal with as an adult
because i experienced it as a young
woman like i grew up a tomboy i played
basketball football better than the boys
so it's like when i would come on to the
field of the court they'd like oh she
can't play because she's a girl
watch me so i think i experienced it as
as a little girl and i've always
overcame that always proved people wrong
i've always proved men wrong so i
wouldn't even put my focus and to
experience it experiencing it in the
industry
um because i've experienced it all my
life but it fuels my ambition to just
prove you know
those who may not see me as an equal
wrong
the way women rap got started off it was
just so beautiful from mc light to queen
latifah to salt and pepper
to
to lauren hill to nikki to foxy to
little kim to trina to eve i'm so happy
that they paved the way for women like
me because
they broke boundaries glass ceilings and
they're just like walking pieces of art
i'm so happy to just
continue the narrative of such a strong
boss woman making a way for herself
i think with pretty [ __ ] music you can
expect me
singing a lot more and just showing more
of like a vulnerable side i've been told
i'm kind of aggressive
for this album i know it's just gonna
you know we're gonna see a different
side of sweetie
i always saw myself getting here i just
didn't know how and i think that was the
most frustrating part at least for me
because i'm like god i know where i'm
headed but what do i got to do
to get there and the answer to that was
just consistency and hard work i think
it's easier for men and women to break
into the genre because of social media
like
anyone can go viral overnight or their
access is just way greater than it was
before you know at first it was passing
mixtapes out
you know on to the street or being
discovered but now it's like you post a
video and if it's good your fan base can
can accumulate you know really quickly
over time the reason why i was posting
wraps on instagram was because i
couldn't afford studio time that was my
way of putting my music out into the
world my biggest advice to women who are
climbing the career ladder
i think
a really important piece of advice that
a lot of us overlook is just knowing
yourself i think the more you know about
yourself the more you can create
boundaries expectations i think you'll
get further
further with your career if you knew
yourself i think that's that's really
important
you